this week we've got lonely NAB bungee
lunch and toilet tornado all right for
the first one so this woman she was left
four hours after a her 90-minute flight
landed she was left four hours inside
all the Air Canada [ __ ] yeah I hate her
guts so I read the article and then she
was just the whole time she's talking
about anxious she was scary but the way
it sounds your ass is afraid of heights
hug dare you call her a [ __ ] little bit
the way she sounds and there's so much
extra anxiety that she put she has an
anxiety disorder take any story and run
it through your [ __ ] filter when
you're in a plane and you wake up as his
dark it was freezing it's just dark and
Freya was it in Alaska Canada sorry can
you please tell me yet so this woman
doing it my voice no can you say this
[ __ ] cuz that's what she is a parent
this poor woman with an anxiety disorder
woke up after several hours she got the
anxiety disorder after she got a lawyer
that's where it came out oh here we go
that's why that's why I think she's a
[ __ ] that's why I think she's a [ __ ]
yeah I don't think she's a [ __ ] trying
to get some funny part she actually got
left on a dark plane I would love to get
left in a dark please let me tell you if
she had an anxiety disorder that would
be anything though if she woke up in
7-eleven or anything yeah yeah I would
be anxious if I woke up at 7 minutes
it's like why am I here
waking up anywhere but your room is
terrifying
yeah even if you spend that your
friend's house you wake up you're like
oh I remember I spent the night you know
anyway you always feel kidnapped
Versailles okay so this woman she said
that when she woke up she was really
cold she felt like she was having a bad
dream she's like how did this [ __ ]
happen cuz the whole plane was empty and
it was dark and so she ended up texting
her friend [ __ ] funny
what what she's laughing Jews just
making fun of this woman she's making
fun of me and now she's got my back
again how dare you it's the way she's
delivering it it's like overdramatize
and then I see this lady I'm like oh but
you're on a [ __ ] plane exactly and
there's plenty of food there's a
restroom but that's how nice Canada is
that they saw somebody peacefully
sleeping it's like we won't wake her up
we'll just keep on going a like yeah so
she says she texted her friend and she
wrote I just woke up alone in plane but
then after sending that one text her
phone died that was one text airplane
mode - yeah yeah so she said that she
was trying to call her friend through
FaceTime and that's when her phone died
and then she tried plugging in her phone
to a youth before but it didn't work
because the plane was off yeah you got
to turn the key on the ignition so then
she went through the constant chin to
the cockpit and she found walkie-talkies
but she was unsuccessfully able to
operate it walkie-talkies walkie-talkies
found walking waited why what does that
matter fee if that's plural because if
she has both of them
[Laughter]
she was able to find a flashlight and so
she was able to like unlock the
emergency exit thing but yeah it was a
40 to 50-foot drop
there was no way she could climb down so
she was able to use that flashlight to
like wave it outside and like the planes
on the ground yeah okay yeah I had
landed for a long time already she woke
up from a nap I hope so cuz the
Conqueror was empty I'm saying like the
planes on the ground I mean they don't
they the emergency exits they have
something to roll out or the emergency
exit is when you exit from the show yeah
that's true the slide right yeah there
should be there right she should have
been able to open the slide and when she
didn't watch the video nobody pays
attention nobody pays attention when
they're doing the seatbelt and you pull
the strings have a kid give it to the
kid first and stuff no you put your so
in the [ __ ] up thing you have to put
it on first okay because what if you put
it on the kid and then you're dying
no I just I just I look out for my kids
like I'd be so like quick but now you're
dead exactly yeah what a good man you
were you got you're both dying you are
cuz you're about to put it on and you
both die later yeah yeah so you gotta go
like that and then at the last minute
you say hey they're way more resilient
you have to think of you and you could
probably make more kids for sure kids
are replaceable you can't make more use
and they're durable yes okay sure they
will to catch the attention of an
airport employee and they helped her get
down yeah so now they're saying that
they're investigating this whole thing
because this was a security violation a
really big security violation the fact
that they left her sleeping on the plane
and she also she had access to secure
areas of the airport operations area
hell yeah that's scary if she was a
terrorist she would be like no [ __ ]
way
sheriff's are taking notes
dan to sleep she's like they gave me the
plane first of all this is Canada in
case you didn't know what they were the
plane we flew it before and then this is
the woman named Tiffany she looks gammy
to you scabby yeah she looks kind of
scare me she was left in a [ __ ]
airplane Jeff do you think that she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I feel like damn that sucks
for you dude I would have freaked out
too but freaky right but I don't think
any of us if we got left in a plane I
don't think any of us would have made
the news because it wouldn't have made a
big fuss about it what we would have
liked just hole it on off the record or
something but we wouldn't have said
anxiety well the security violations all
this I know but we would just lawsuit
there's a lawsuit oh I didn't mention it
yet but she they are saying that she
does have grounds for a lawsuit not that
she has fire making your own use over
there she barked she's not suing you man
feels like she is yeah they're saying
that she could argue that the airline
was negligent securing the plane she's
right yeah and that she is do actual
damage well the articles trying to
instigate a lawsuit yeah the hard part
to swallow here is what I find very fun
and something that I would like to do
she sees it as a nightmare so I'm like
you're not appreciating your situation
lady how can you you know like for me
like I [ __ ] love skydiving if I'm
wrong you'll be pissed that someone at
it is like a so terrified of sky I'm
terrified of it but I would never talk
[ __ ] on your situation like if I have to
jump out of the plane I play but I would
never sit on it no way she's [ __ ] on
someone else's dream right now you
wouldn't try to sue tip for damages nope
yeah I mean I don't feel like man I
always wanted to wake up inside of a
mall all right well anyway speaking of
thrilling a tip I agree with that
thrilling activities this woman from
China she's a theme park employee and
she has gone viral on social media
because every single day she bungee
jumps to deliver lunch to other
employees that are pretty far away just
lunch just get rector's in a tossed
salad every day okay it's probably
stir-fry words I like that it's probably
stir-fry so it's always mixed yeah it's
already mixed already wait till she
bungee jumps to delivery yeah they're at
the bottom and she's like there you go
I'll show you the video I'll show you
why
wait where's the food it's strapped to
her must not be that many employ my god
that looks fun
I'm getting goose bumps just watches
that's crazy
no way just for to know that's kind of
good it looks hella good you know be fun
I didn't appreciate that she's landed
stained and then game I wanted her to
hand it as like yeah let her go boo yeah
yeah yeah so the thing is that some of
these employees at the theme park work
at the bottom of the Melton which would
usually take about 30 minutes to reach
by car and by then the lunch will be
cold
Oh but because of this new procedure
here it just takes two minutes to
deliver this so the drop heats it back
up so it takes our 30 minutes to go back
up to the theme park or whatever I'm
assuming that's so nice but what about
like if she forgets condom into [ __ ] so
she goes down so she has to drive all
the way up or that's how she makes it
exciting like a she's coming down so you
bring the food come back up and then
bring the napkins and they go yeah
there's more every drop that'd be dope
if she just jumped and it gives it to
him and then it flies back up and
you know the the bungee jump has the
retraction and just goes back up what
would be the most extreme thing you guys
would be done and do for some lunch for
some lunch to give lunch or to get lunch
yeah get it I know I'd ride a bike we
would we went to Compton to get some
barbecue that was pretty extreme and
that was a that's pretty scary the thing
that sucks about this is that like you
can't change it up you can never do
pizza there never having no pizza
back the slices in the same box
oh I see that's pretty creative did you
see the lunch though it had like
compartments and it was yeah it was I
still on the top I'm disappointed I
wanted her to have a big-ass backpack
with a bunch of [ __ ] lunch and then
it's like a crew of like 20 people then
I'm like spider-man style it's like
boying and in here and then enjoy that
lunch hello much though because I knew
that it came from like such a high place
this is how I feel about about uber
delivery how they're gonna do it through
the sky it's like get McDonald's through
the sky and I'm like it'll it'll be cold
it'll be all the wind will [ __ ] get
in the package like drove drunk drunk
drunk delivery oh my god yeah like magic
eating fast food but through a drone
delivery well like that's fast if they
put it in a box and it's not like a bag
just like a call like you're imagining
like a claw holding a bag like this but
if they put it in like a warm containers
or a cold one you know like the Pizza
Hut heat wave yeah oh that could be good
warm in there there's a drug holding a
[ __ ] cup like this and it's all
spilling there's [ __ ] bugs and [ __ ]
damn well what about for your dogs then
like what would be like the craziest
[ __ ] you'd be willing to do cuz this is
this [ __ ] channel would be skydiving
so bad you want to eat lunch well sky
I'm saying now I never use my job
delivering like bungees like no no like
listen to do the tandem skydiving thing
with all like you become an instructor
but I think I'm too small for that I
mean an instructor yeah like a skydiving
thing like that would be my dream
why do you there's like this euphoric
feeling like there's a soul every time
yeah every time you're doing 3 oh nice I
only wants my grub done done it twice
but them doing that job they're like
even to do it without any person
attached to you you got to like a
thousand jump yeah yeah like four levels
before you could even attach someone I
like the flying squirrel one like that's
the one my buddy does that wingsuit [ __ ]
really yeah how surprising not dead
how do you train for them all they have
to do like these done like 6,000 jumps
or some [ __ ] you know the people that
invented the wingsuit and have advanced
the technology in it it took a hundred
different I guess scientists to help
progress it guess how many of those guys
are alive still zero zero because they
all tested and I have a buddy that does
it and then he's I was like what's the
feeling like and he goes so the feeling
is imagine yet you grab like two two
pound or five pound dumbbells and you
have to be able to hold it like this
three minutes straight because if you
collapse your wings then you're done so
you have to build the endurance to be
able to hold your arms out like you're
holding dumbbells and you're just I
would have done if you do this then
you'll like go faster you will but y'all
ready go and wait you're fast yeah
because you have milliseconds to pull
your chute before you're like cuz splat
see that's also what I hate about the
instructors they have these witty a
skydiving jokes if you land or if the
parachute goes up every time you're
going up all right good luck savor your
last see ya hopefully I'm like bro can
you stop jumping
alright moving on to our last story here
in Massachusetts
there was this blockage that caused raw
sewage to come up the toilet of four
homes
disgusting yeah we almost have oh [ __ ]
oh yeah better know what the story is
but what you're saying we just had that
at JK
oh yeah the downtown office you know you
[ __ ] all over the floors ya know the
Dukes came out Wow and that's the only
shot outs to Julia Brandon now said and
I think Brian everybody helped
because after Jake a party one day I
heard oh my god
and then by the time I got out there it
was halfway clean and I said good job
guys you didn't help for the rest of the
half way no I watched it and I was like
that's tight to Duke right there leaked
all the way to a conference room oh just
the toilets just [ __ ] flooded like
the fountain of [ __ ] well maybe I think
it was Sean Sean boys seem like a big
[ __ ]
well you said both toilets right I just
won it was the shower one Oh what was
the other one broke into any randomly
did a result of all the pipes the other
one just went to the top and went back
down and [ __ ] wait Sean took such a big
[ __ ] that it got in the pipes and then
it clogged all the toilets up that's a
manly [ __ ] yeah Indian food so here's a
video of one of the residents
experiencing this tornado of poop they
call it oh god it smells so bad in this
Oh buddy the city water supplies come on
she did not have carpeting oh yeah we'd
be like soaked in there mildew oh that's
the worst that's like [ __ ] 10,000
people [ __ ] wet feed me that's a
bathroom in the walking dead dude mm
that's expired [ __ ] - yeah all I can
press this photo that is oh that's a lot
of [ __ ] that's more [ __ ] than if all of
us just took a [ __ ] right now that's
like a month's worth of [ __ ] I'd rather
be homeless if I said [ __ ] I might
moving out you can't clean after that it
won't it won't ever be fresh yeah you
have to just kiss all your belongings
walk
did ya just walk away there was runt one
wrench residents who said that it will
take weeks to clean and repair her home
because all the floors and the walls
like to come out and like the entire you
need to [ __ ] burn the house down you
get a [ __ ] chance on you cut off that
whole part you need to get a [ __ ]
priest to exercise that be such her
wedding dress like she found her wedding
dress soaked in it marriage know their
homes so how did this happen so yeah
like one of Sean big [ __ ] Sean man yeah
one of the main lines in that
neighborhood got blocked and that's why
they're these four homes I just
experienced all this do they know how it
got blocked no sure his mom's house um
it was backed up and it was because in
so this you know the city plants trees
along the sidewalk so the roots of the
tree started going into the pipe oh damn
yes it kept block that's a strong gas
tree right but the [ __ ] up thing
they're like well you guys have to like
like pay for it if you guys want it
repaired dad damn I thought they met
with like home owner insurance is like
home assurance it only covers certain
things yeah whose tree is it the city's
that's their fault no it's all your
pipes or yeah I'm like [ __ ] your trees
is everything under under you yours yeah
yeah well if that's the case I'm gonna
make tunnels then [ __ ] the city yeah
right that's just gonna be mine I mean
the people to blame could be the Chinese
contractors my mom hired could they use
[ __ ] pipe probably would sort of clear
the roots out or did it legit but they
want to move so fast that the Bulls and
they let the roots go in tucked it in
yeah oh yeah hey Bobby thought the trees
would help grow like if the roots sucked
a [ __ ]
yeah it's like the floor fertilizer I
know like this
does your mom own that entire land that
she does up up until the sidewalk the
sidewalk is the city yeah so like none
of the plumbing under or even the
plumbing and the electrical stuff like
that's all owned by the homeowner up to
the up to the sidewalk yeah and then
from the pipes on is the city so many
rules
yeah but dude if this should happen to
my house I'm I'm [ __ ] movin like put
that I'm not go everybody wanna buy
houses and do the contrast like how do
you even clean all that [ __ ] run away
that easy I don't understand how you how
you even begin to clean something like
that up I would give up me neither I
don't know what's it down the toilet
right and you can't even use your own
toilet with it you gotta burn your house
down this what I'm saying I can't open
your cabinets I'm just thinking like
what do I reach for if you're up and if
you're a below so just the whole tank
you try to [ __ ] spray Febreze is okay
to like how do you use the bathroom you
go downstairs and take a [ __ ] on top of
all that that's just a toilet
[Laughter]
[Music]